ein drittel unseres lebens verschlafen
und vertrauen wir der bekannt der
wissenschaftsautor steht von klein und
die schlaf forscherin und klar träumerin
männer nicht schädlich beschäftigen sich
mit dem träumen
das sind träume wie funktionieren sie
können wir sogar lernen und unsere
träume zu steuern
freilich gibt es träume über die sie
nicht sprechen
ja gibt es da wären
das fängt ja nicht darüber wie klein sie
sehen das ähnlich
ich spreche über alle meine träume die
frage ist wie ausführlich ich das tue
also ich würde in bestimmten erotischen
träumen vielleicht nicht erzählen wer
die damen waren die durch die begeistert
sind
ich glaube wir haben zu viel charme im
umgang mit unseren träumen und das kommt
daher dass wir gelernt haben dass träume
etwas verboten ist etwas gefährlich ist
und ich glaube träume sind etwas
wunderbares und es ist zeit dass wir das
wahrnehmen und dass wir darüber sprechen
aber haben wir nicht gerade gelernt seit
27 dass wir eben diesen verborgenen
dingen umgehen können dürfen
naja sigmund freud das ist 114 jahre her
und seitdem haben wir eine menge neues
gelernt und es gibt dann leute wie
melanie schädlich die arbeiten daran
dass wir noch mehr neues über träume
lernen sigmund freud hat er eine ganz
komische zugang zu unseren träumen der
hat uns nämlich versucht glauben zu
machen dass der traum den wir erinnern
und erzählen so was wie eine lüge ist
und darunter und darunter liege ein
latenter traum und der handel dann
wirklich davon dass ich meine mutter
umbringen will und mit meinem vater
schlafen oder genau umgekehrt was weiß
nämlich und dann ist das ganz natürlich
dass sich leute ich schon über ihre
träume zu sprechen weil wollen sie
gefragt werden ob sie lieber mit ihrer
mutter oder ihren vater geschlafen
hätten
jetzt sind wir bei mir das natürlich
sehr kompliziert und ich muss ja gott
sei dank nicht auskunft geben
meine zwei wissen vielleicht ziehen
detail darauf eingehen aber zuerst
müssen wir vielleicht noch einmal sagen
was sie gehabt ich quasi da rahmen des
tragens nämlich dass schlaf was
passiert im schlaf was ist schlaf ja
also es gibt verschiedene schlaf stadien
die wir jede nacht durchlaufen
und ja es ist eigentlich gut frage war
so ist schlaf also wenn wir jetzt auch
wieder auf den traum zurückkommen ist es
so dass wir heute eigentlich wissen dass
sie die ganze nacht träumen also zwar
auf verschiedene arten aber es gibt
verschiedene schlaf stadien und schon
beim einschlafen das kennen viele leute
vielleicht auch sieht man so gewisse
bilder vorsichtig dann so langsam in den
traum übergehen schlaf also meine hinter
seit wir menschen sind seit ich eine
geschichte schreiben
mythen kennen ist das schlafzimmer auch
der bruder des todes wir haben quasi die
vorstellung wir haben uns den gott des
schlafens schlafes thanatos der kurzen
die beiden sind brüder ist es so dass
wir nicht einfach ganz nahe beim nichts
beim tod beim absinken nein überhaupt
nicht
überhaupt nicht und ich glaube das ist
eine der großen erkenntnissen die uns
die schlafforschung na ja schon seit
einem jahr ein paar jahrzehnten aber in
voller schärfe erst in der letzten zeit
beschert hat dass unser geist unser
gehirn im schlaf eben überhaupt nicht
passiv ist schlaf ist nicht einfach ein
ruhezustand wo alles runter gefahren
wird sondern das gehirn ist während wir
schlafen
genauso aktiv in manchen teilen sogar
aktiver als wenn wir wachen ist es nur
eben anders dann aktiv und wir und wir
brauchen den schlaf für unser wach leben
und nicht einfach nur weil wir uns
ausruhen müssen sind sie ich vergleiche
das gern mit dem kochen eines
mehrgängigen essen es nicht also wenn
sie also wenn sie intensiv kochen dann
entsteht eine bestimmte unordnung in der
küche und sie müssen und sie müssen die
küche aufräumen sie müssen sich sie
müssen sich reorganisieren
und genau das passiert im schlaf im
schlaf reorganisiert sich unser gehirn
und das erleben wir als träumen und
dieses träume leben wir haben leider
gottes eben nicht als etwas sehr aktives
wie die küche aufräumen sondern es wird
ja quasi aufgeräumt für einnehmen
na ja da gibt es ja unterschiedliche
grade an aktivität nicht das gibt es von
vollkommen passiv zu vollkommen aktiv
nicht also es gibt ja träume dabei ist
dass ich träume und da kann ich sogar
eingreifen und es gibt es gibt alle
zwischenstufen also ich glaube es wäre
ganz falsch sich den schlaf als einen
als einen zustanden vorzustellen das ist
so ein auf und ab 1000 eben dazu naja
natürlich eine vorbereitet was sie sehen
hier quasi diese diese kurven wie sie
genannt haben können sie vielleicht kurz
diese schlaf dramaturgie uns uns
erklären die beine ganze nacht genau
also zunächst hat man beim einschlafen
dann erst mal so ein leicht schlaf wo
man auch bilder sehen kann
geräusche hören kann unter umständen die
nimmt nicht jeder war dann geht es
relativ zügig direkt in die erste
tiefschlafphase der nacht da ist man zum
beispiel sehr schwer daraus nur zu
wecken dann nach der ersten
tiefschlafphase geht es über den live
schlaf dann in die erste rem schlafphase
rem-schlaf steht für rapid eye movement
es ist dieses schlaf phase in der wir
diese schnellen augenbewegungen haben
die man auch gut bei babys zum beispiel
oder bei haustieren beobachten kann
diese erste rem schlafphase ist sehr
kurz und dann taucht wie direct ziemlich
schnell wieder in den tiefschlaf ab und
insgesamt ist das quasi so dass wir in
der ersten nachthälfte überwiegend
tiefschlaf am in der zweiten dann
überwiegend rem schlaf und immer
längeren schlaf und sie soll in der
klassischen zwei um forschung hat man
ist man davon ausgegangen dass man nur
in der endphase träumen dass in einer
relativ kurzen phase der das des ganzen
schlaf prozesses und das ist
offensichtlich mal verträumt also quasi
durch in verschiedensten geraten und
stadien auch der aktivität und
passivität
das haben das kurz kranke das
interessiert mich quasi wenn man ab dass
es gibt lähmungen und man ist wirklich
abgeschottet von der außenwelt in der
rem schlaf gehabt dass diese lähmung
genau
und jetzt gibt es aber einen speziellen
traum hat das klarträumen ich werden wir
quasi von den passiven des zuschauer
oder involviert aber nicht direkt
können graf eingreifen sie selber haben
erfahrungen mit klar 2 das heißt sie
sind aktiv beim träumen aktiv würde ich
nicht benutzten den ausdruck also der
ausdruck klartraum oder luzider traum
hast heißt eigentlich erst mal nichts
anderes als dass ich mir im traum
bewusst bin zu träumen das heißt während
ich schlafe während ich träume weiß ich
das ist mein traum ich muss dann nicht
aktiv den traum umgestalten weil der
traum immer noch ein eigenleben hat ich
kann auch einfach nur bewusst sagen ich
gucke mir jetzt diese faszinierende welt
an und gucke was ist denn überhaupt ist
der traum
natürlich werde ich auch öfter aktiv und
überleg mir dann jetzt möchte ich gerne
fliegen oder irgendwas bestimmt das tun
nicht mit traum charakteren unterhalten
oder ein gedicht schreiben und daran
können sie sich daran erinnern zusammen
andere morgen aufwacht
ja also ich kann hier fragen natürlich
nicht eindeutig beantworten weil es
möglich ist dass das klar träume gibt
eigentlich mich nicht erinnern kann
aber ich erinnere mich öfter ein klar
träume richtig aber das heißt sie haben
in ihrem buch über die zäune klein
geschrieben dass wir wie sie die ganzen
350 millionen evolutionsgeschichte in
einer nach noch einmal passieren
das heißt ich kann nicht quasi an meinen
teil dazu stand auch erinnern oder kann
noch viel besser sie können wenn sie aus
dem tiefschlaf geweckt werden dann
können sie sich vielleicht sogar daran
erinnern wie er es gewesen sein mag und
von einem bieter sei ja eine eine biene
oder eine oder eine ameise gewesen zu
sein was eines was ich so faszinierend
finden an träumen ist sie zeigen uns
verschiedene zustände des gehirns nicht
und unser geist das ist eben nicht nur
ein ding der so ist wie wir es
vielleicht tagsüber erleben sondern ich
vergleiche das viel eher wie mit dem den
schichten einer zwiebel nicht also da
ist eine schicht da sind gefühle da ist
eine schicht das in erinnerung da ist
eine schicht da ist wille da ist eine
schicht denken da ist eine schicht
wahrnehmen usw
und diese diese zwiebel entblättert sich
in der nacht und da können sie in die da
können sie in die aller interessantesten
zustände kommen nicht also ganz häufig
im traum erleben wir zum beispiel wir
haben einen ganz starken willen
aber der wille ist nicht frei also ich
will etwas unbedingt haben aber ich kann
mich gar nicht anders entscheiden oder
ich erlebe meine meine erinnerungen ja
ich bin wieder in meinem elternhaus ich
bin ein kind aber ich weiß nicht das ist
meine erinnerungen sind dann gibt es
natürlich wenn sie von neandertalern und
steinzeitmenschen sprechen dann gibt es
phasen in denen sie von ganz intensiven
gefühlen getrieben sind diese überhaupt
nicht mehr rational steuern und
reflektieren können und da gibt es in
der tat vermutungen dass das ein zustand
sein mag in dem menschen in einer
früheren phase ja ich einander in einer
früheren phase unserer
entwicklungsgeschichte tatsächlich
gelebt haben dass bestimmte störungen
leben also rem schlafstörungen nennt man
das erleben menschen das wirklich aus
also die die schreien und die benehmen
sich als wären sie tiere ist das deckt
sich jetzt das mit ihren klarträumen
auch weil natürlich nicht nicht also
theoretisch könnte es natürlich auch
zusammen fallen weil eine störung ist
unabhängig davon
naja aber wenn du aber aber immer im
klartraum der funktionierte gerade
dadurch dass die dass das kritische
denken im schlaf zugeschaltet wird
das ist ein verein der sich in einer
bestimmten traum szenerie wiedersieht
und dabei weiß es erträumt aber trotzdem
physiologisch physisch mit dem körper
seine sachen aus agiert das ist trotzdem
möglich
sie haben ja klar aber erfahrung als er
es hat aber an sich nichts miteinander
zu tun der seine schlafstörungen und
klar träume ist etwas was man menschen
einfach natürlich weise haben oder was
man lernen kann er sich nicht also ich
glaube um das
um das klar zu machen dass wir also dass
wir nachts in eine vollkommen archaische
welt eintauchen das ist keine störung
das ist vollkommen normal und das ist
vollkommen faszinierend finde ich
wir sind in der endphase normalerweise
glücklicherweise gelingt ja wir sind
vollkommen gelähmt das einzige was sich
bewegt das zentrieren
das sind die augen und diese und diese
lähmung ist im gewissen sinn ein schutz
also dass wir das nicht außerhalb für
die in welt ja für die frau die neben
mir also es sind meistens männer die
diese störung haben und die fangen dann
an ihre frauen zu verprügeln ohne dass
sie das neue einfach weil die ihre
bewegungen nicht kontrollieren können
diese lähmung ist ein schutz und die
störung besteht nur darin in
anführungsstrichen nur dass die lähmung
aufgehoben ist wenn wir jetzt aber noch
einmal das faszinosum der ak kein
bisschen verlassen und sagen es gibt
offensichtlich sphären die unser eigenes
ich direkt angehen wo man sich
vielleicht wieder in einem spiegel
findet da sind wir bei den inhalten und
die inhalte sind natürlich so dass die
seit freud auch und in der ganzen kunst
des 20 jahrhunderts permanent die
künstler und die kreativen intensiv
beschäftigt hat wir haben ein beispiel
von einem alfred hitchcock film
spellbound gregory peck einen solchen
traum erzählt
plötzlich sah ich auf dem abschüssigen
dach eines hohen gebäudes den mann mit
dem bart stehen ich schrieb ihm zu er
solle aufpassen
dann fiel herunter langsam den füßen
nach oben
dann sah ich wieder den besitzer den
mann mit der maske
er lobte in einem schornstein abfuhr
erhielt ein kleines rad in der hand
ich sage das rad auf das dach fallen
ließ
[Applaus]
[Musik]
plötzlich fing ich an zu laufen ich
hörte über mir etwas draussen es war ein
großes flügel an flügel verfolgten mich
bis an den fuß eines hügels
ich muss entkommen sagen mir weiß ich
nicht mehr wissen sie nicht die träume
wie als klar träumerin als forscherin
dann wenn wir jedes jahr für eine solche
filmsequenz von salvador dalí also weit
ein sehr bitteres traum beispiel was so
an sich aber jetzt erstmal nicht
ungewöhnlich ist wenn man jetzt
natürlich in so einer szene klar wird
kann man sich natürlich überlegen ob man
da irgendwie einschreitet als weizen
sehr gruselige stimmung diese bedrohung
lag in der luft dass man da als träumen
dass ich irgendwie versucht das
umzukehren
ich fand jetzt aber halt auch auffällig
dass dieses musikgenre skurril war also
die meisten träume beinhalten jetzt
nicht eine art filmmusik wie diese wobei
ich mich an ein zwei träume erinnern
kann die eine art filmmusik als
begleitung hatte und auffällig war auch
dass es in schwarz weiß war schwarz-weiß
sie sagt mir ein buch das ist eine
periode gab im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
wo die menschen glaubten sie hätten
schwarz-weiß gezogen weil das kino und
und gerade ältere menschen sagen dass
immer noch die sind mit die sind mit
schwarz weiß filmen dann später auch mit
dem schwarz weiß fernsehen groß geworden
und haben sich einfach daran gewöhnen
dass bewegt ich bin das schwarze und das
haben die vollkommen natürlicherweise
auf ihre träume übertragen also bei den
bei den ersten beiden ersten
systematischen untersuchungen die
gemacht worden sind so in den 50er und
frühen 60er jahren da haben tatsächlich
die meisten leute gesagt sie träumen in
schwarz weiß
wenn sie heute diese umfragen
wiederholen dann sagen die meisten leute
sie träumen in farbe tatsächlich ist die
leute haben immer in farbe geträumt das
wissen wir aus aus weg und versuchen ja
wenn ich die direkt auf dem schlaf auf
und dann sagen sie ja klar ich habe ich
habe phasen gesehen das ist die traum
erinnerung die den die rückblickend den
traum entsprechend unseren erwartungen
verzerren
also das heißt also emotionen ist ein
wichtiges schlagwort wie gesagt das sind
die gefühle ja und es ist dass sie
ist ein visueller reize es ist ja
weniger das gehör der geruch also es ist
halt ähnlich wie tagsüber also unser
haupt sind tagsüber ist ja auch das
sehen
an zweiter stelle das hören und ähnlich
ist es in träumen wobei es da auch
unterschiede gibt es gibt viele leute
die auch sagen ich spreche nie in träume
oder ich die leute in meinen träumen
sprechen nicht aber bei mir spielt das
gehört zum beispiel auch immer eine
rolle
und dann untergeordnet der stelle stehen
riechen schmecken ist aber möglich und
wie ist es eigentlich wenn jemand blind
oder taub ist wie träumen blinde ja die
träumen ja erstaunlicherweise trotzdem
in bildern und das ist wirklich eine das
ist eine das ist eine ganz erstaunliche
erkenntnis das hat sehr lange gebraucht
bis man das also wirklich zweifelsfrei
festgestellt hat dann wenn sie die also
wenn sie also wenn sie die blinden sie
müssen blind geborene nehmen da ist
besonders interessant werden
sie haben die bilder gesehen ja jetzt
fragen sie die schönsten bilder nur
sagen die ihnen natürlich nein das ist
genauso wie das ist die erwartung nicht
ich sehe hat über keine bilder das ist
wie mit dem die mit dem schwarz weiß
wenn sie die aber in der nacht aufwecken
dann können die ihn plötzlich von
bildern berichten und in einer
untersuchung die gemacht man nicht haben
diese bilder sogar gibt es wir haben
eine eine solche zeit da sie ja ja das
ist das ist aus einer untersuchung von
hector bertolo unter theresa paiva
das ist ein blind geboren und da sind
sie der zeichnete ein schiffchen
unterzeichnet die sonne jetzt ist die
frage wo kommen diese bilder her nun
diese bilder hier haben wir ein hier
haben wir ein gehirn die kommen die
kommen aus dem visuellen kortex aus der
aus der serie und das und die erzeugt
einfach bild auch wenn das auge nicht
funktioniert also und sonne ein
segelschiff eine palme bringen
das wie das aussehen muss oder aussehen
könnte das wissen diese leute aus
erzählungen
vielleicht haben sie auch einmal ein ein
schiffchen modell getestet und das und
das übersetzen die automatisch im bilde
und sehen sie das ist genau das was wir
die ganze nacht machen in der nacht sind
unsere augen abgeschaltet das sind wir
gewissermaßen blind wir sind nicht blind
geboren aber wir sind blind und wir
übersetzen das was in uns vorgeht in
bildern bei diesem angst trauben in
spellbound den wir gerade gesehen haben
da wird ein ganz starkes gefühl bilder
übersetzt also das wiederum diese art
unterstützt wenn wir sagen es geht ums
für jenes geht um angst das geht
natürlich geht es oft auch um 6
natürlich in sinsheim das haben sie ganz
eingangs offen offen gesagt also diese
ad-hoc mit der wir irgendwie umzugehen
versuchen das heißt im traum dass wir
aber nicht an dieses symbolhaftigkeit
glauben müssen sondern an eine reihe al
attiyah an etwas an etwas viel
unmittelbarere es nämlich zb an einem
gefühl also die ich glaube der einer von
vielen fehlern der symbolischen
traumdeutung ist also die würden dann
bei diesem hitchcock beispiel fragen wie
also sehe wer ist der mann mit der maske
und ich würde sagen das ist überhaupt
nicht wichtig der mann mit dem der mann
hat kein gesicht weil da einfach
information fehlt und das wirklich
tragende das tragende in diesem traum
das ist das gefühl und das ist die angst
und wenn ich einen zugang zu meinen
träumen finden wenn dann das beste und
das einfach das direkt aus dem was man
machen es sich zu fragen wie hast du
dich dabei gefühlt also das heißt diese
vermittlung darauf möchte ich gern noch
zu sprechen kommen quasi zwischen dem
was im try & passiert und dass ihr davon
wissen wie man diesen zugang schafft das
ist sicher etwas was die
neurowissenschaft und zu erklären kann
aber zum anderen wenn wir noch einmal
sagen sowie als fazit die frage das
kommt das was wir als bewusstsein haben
von innen oder von außen
das kommt von ascom sagen irgendwann
kommen ja ja und das ist es und da und
das ist das was freuen wir uns lehren
die die welt entsteht in unserem kopf ok
also in der realität auch in der
realität genau das wird dann nur die
realität das wird ein bisschen
korrigiert durch das was wir sehen aber
im wesentlichen sind das hypothesen die
wir uns bilden und im traum kann man
einfach zuschauen wie das
24 und das finde ich so faszinierend
daran gut also das heißt dass die
wissenschaft sich offensichtlich für das
sehr stark interessiert was vorgeht um
auch etwas über das gehirn zu verstehen
also ist der traum quasi der schlüssel
zu einer art von bewusstheit und
identität kann man so aussehen her auf
ein fehler
und was war eigentlich für sie fertig
ausgangspunkt sich wissenschaftlich mit
den trainern und dem thema
auseinanderzusetzen ja eigentlich bin
ich auch über die persönliche
erfahrungen dazu gekommen also ich hab
mich schon sehr lange für träume an sich
interessiert da war auch für die
bedeutung von träumen was auch immer das
heißen mag und habe dann mit 19 von den
klarträumen erfahren das ist es gibt und
jetzt hat man das ist klar
ich habe einen artikel zugeschickt
bekommen da rüber geschickt geschrieben
wurde
so habe ich erfahren wollten sie auch
das heißt sie nicht gern mit
also es gibt leute die von kind an öfter
natürliche weise klar träume oder es
entsteht in der pubertät ist kommt auch
öfter vor aber ich habe es mit 19
erfahren dass es gibt und dachte genial
man kann seine träume bewusst wahrnehmen
und vielleicht auch steuern das will ich
mir beibringen und dann habe ich mir das
beigebracht und da begann eigentlich die
faszination als ich dann sogar den
ersten paar traum hatte und dieses
freiheitsgefühl so dieses diese
erkenntnis ich wache in meiner eigenen
inneren welt auf weiß aber ich liege
eigentlich im bett und schlafe und
damals hatte ich sowieso für psychologie
zu studieren und dann gegen ende meines
studiums habe ich mir gedacht ja warum
sollte ich das nicht anfangen zu
erforschen und dann habe ich mit diplom
arbeit angefangen und jetzt in der
doktorarbeit setzt fort und was uns
jetzt natürlich alle brennend
interessiert wie lernt man das ja also
es gibt sehr sehr viele möglichkeiten
also das internet ist auch voll davon
man kann schon mal grundsätzlich
unterscheiden es gibt mentale techniken
mit denen man sich vorbereitet dass man
im traum erkennt dass man träumt und es
gibt die möglichkeit direkt vom
wachzustand in den klartraum
einzusteigen aber das lasse ich mal
außen vor wald ist auch er was für
fortgeschrittene klar träumer ist diese
mentalen techniken zum beispiel ganz
einfach dass man tagsüber sich öfter die
frage ich die nachricht gerade oder troy
mich gerade
man sollte das auch wirklich überprüfen
weil man sich sonst falls man sich im
traum fragt das auch logisch zu recht
erklären kann auch wenn es eigentlich
nicht logisch ist und überprüfen kann
man es an sogenannten realitätstest also
indem man zum beispiel seine finger
zählt solche bis 5 und die sehen auch
ziemlich normal aus wenn ich das im
traum mache habe ich oft mehr finger
oder die verzweigen sich oder ein teil
wird unsichtbar das heißt dass diese das
eine eine kleine horror vision die sich
von mir auftut wenn sie das erzählen
also das würde heißen dass das was wir
als klar wirklichkeit wahrnehmen und das
was wir als traumwelten dass diese dinge
gleich gleich auf gleicher ebene singen
also weil man sich die frage stellt ja
tagsüber es geht eigentlich nur darum
dass man das oft macht um das in den
traum zu übernehmen weil wir wissen ja
auch dass wir von dingen die wir im
alltag öfter tun auch wieder träumen
oder von besonderen dingen die uns
einfach tagsüber passieren dass taucht
im traum oft wieder auf nach der
kontinuität hypothese und genauso wenn
ich jetzt öfter am tag mich frage wach
ich oder troy mich gerade es ist
wahrscheinlich dass ist das im traum
auch mache auch so und also das heißt
können aber trotzdem sind die beiden
ebenen miteinander verschränkt oder
verlag und ich finde dass keine ich
finde dass keine ich finde dass keine
horror vision sondern schrecklich wenn
ich nicht weiß ob ich mache oder träumen
aber ganze zeit greifen muss um gemeint
aber was lange schauen sie mal an was
sie was sie tun
sie werden sich einfach über ihren
bewusstseinszustand klarer also es gibt
es gibt wunderbare untersuchungen die
zeigen dass menschen so typischerweise
die hälfte ihrer wachzeit die sind
überhaupt nicht da nicht also das will
ich jetzt bei uns ist ganz nah dran
glauben also sie konzentrieren sich
jetzt gerade aber wenn wir dann nachher
mit der s bahn nach hause fahren dann
sind ja dann sind sie also physisch sind
sie vielleicht in der s-bahn aber sie
tagträumen sie denken an ganz was
anderes
das sind zustände und das ist und das
ist neurophysiologische gezeigt die
einer traum realität erstaunliche
ähnlich sah das ähnlich das besser
kontrollieren also in einem dieser
abgang nicht hingeben
ja na klar also sind also sie sind nicht
in einem tiefen rem zustand dass
das stimmt schon aber sie haben sie
haben genauso innere bilder die sind die
sind blasser sie schweifen ab sie sind
sprunghaft und das und das merken sie im
grunde genommen erst dann wenn ein
äußerer reize wo bist du gerade und dann
ja ich bin hier
das ist die hälfte der zeit sind wir
nicht da da sind wir in einem albtraum
zustand und wenn wir jetzt den
unterschiedlichen des buches nehmen
würden also eine reise in unsere innere
wirklichkeit dass das tags wie nachts
passiert und wir haben in die innere
entwickeln
es gibt es gibt keine scharfe grenze es
ist es ist eben nicht so dass unser
geist abgeschaltet wird wenn wir das
nicht abschalten und wieder angeschaltet
wird wenn es in der früh wieder
anschalten
apropos schalten einschalten abschalten
also die apparate mit denen man diesen
zugriff auf das was passiert im gehirn
hat diese werte zu mute ist immer besser
und sophie zitiert man wie kommt man an
diese träume richtig ran und wir haben
ein beispiel ein 1 1 1 für mich sehr
auch wieder irritieren das video dass
wir uns schnell an scheidung vielleicht
eher klein
denn sie das kurz dokumentieren ja also
was da gemacht worden das sind träume im
scanner da wird ein traum gefilmt und
wie macht man das
man hat vorher geguckt wie reagieren die
gehirne dieser menschen auf bilder die
man ihnen zahlen da gibt es ein
bestimmtes aktivitätsmuster und dieses
aktivitätsmuster wird in der nacht
wieder abgespielt im gehirn und das und
das können sie messen da sind hier zb
aktivitätsmuster für buchstaben jetzt
wecken sie die auf und dann sagt dieser
mensch also was ich gerade gesehen habe
waren so eine art buchstaben und so
weiter und so fort die party ist
die wissenschaftler haben das schon
vorher gewusst weil wir haben genau die
haben genau dieses aktivitätsmuster
gemessen
das ist 2012 in japan gemacht worden es
geht inzwischen bei uns es geht
inzwischen bei uns auch was das unter
anderem zeigt ist dass träume eben nicht
etwas sind wie häufig vermutet sonst was
wir uns so zusammen spinnen beim beim
aufwachen sondern das sind erlebnisse
die wir wirklich in der nacht haben und
die sind in einem gewissen sinn
objektive sind objektiv in dem sind als
dass sie das messen
ich finde das nicht unheimlich ich finde
das faszinierend wahrscheinlich sie sie
arbeiten in diesem feld ja also ich
würde trotzdem nicht sagen dass sie
komplett objektiv sind
weil also wie sie auch schon gesagt
haben man hat ja vorher schon diese
buchstaben und so weiter geteilt und
kann dann diese muster wieder entdecken
aber es ist ja jetzt trotzdem nicht so
dass man irgendwie ganz normale leute zu
hause andockt und dann genau das
abspielen kann
und da ist man ja wieder dabei das waren
jetzt nur visuelle dinge man kann ja nie
den traum so erfassen wir wirklich ist
mit der emotionen die er oft sehr
vordergründig ist ja mit emotionen und
allen sinnen und wahrnehmungen
also wir in der traum forschung haben
dann natürlich auch das problem dass man
an den traum im moment nur über die
erinnerung reinkommt das heißt wir
müssen bedeutet das alte dilemma offen
heraus forschungen sind wir dann halt
leute fragen was hast du gerade geträumt
und in dem moment wo die person das in
sprache fast es ist natürlich schon
wieder eingegrenzt ist nicht genau das
was die person erlebt hat und na ja aber
da finde ich also das finde ich solche
arbeiten schon wirklich einen großen
schritt nach vorne also sie also sie
können natürlich vollkommen zu recht
einwenden das ist das ist alles noch
furchtbar ungenau
das ist das stimmt die geräte sind noch
nicht gut es geht es geht übrigens
inzwischen auch mit bewegungen das hat
die das hat die münchner gruppe gemacht
also wenn sie mir vor fünf jahren das
erzählt hätten der hälfte seiner kommen
also träume aktie leute das ist doch
science fiction das hat das hat er wim
wenders gefilmt in seinem film bis an
die reise eine reise bis ans ende der
welt und das ist heute realität und ich
glaube in zehn jahren werden wir noch
viel viel bessere daten habe die
klartraum forschung wenn ich das richtig
verstehen würde
sie haben ein bewusstsein während des
traums das helfen kann
um diese diese bilder zu verifizieren
ohne über das medium der sprache beim
aufwachen zu gehen also das heißt sie
sind wirklich
die abokarte dieser traum wird und man
kann natürlich auch klar träume in den
scanner legen dann hat man es
koordiniert und kann dann natürlich
direkt diese aktivitäten nachweisen eben
zum beispiel wenn man die hand
zusammendrückt und man nutzt in dem fall
hat das klarträumen als mittel weil man
diesen träumen sagen kann wenn du
träumst macht davon dass zum beispiel
drückt die hand zusammen und klar träume
können kommunizieren während des traumes
stehle hat das zusätzlich also
unabhängige jetzt von diesen scanner
sachen kann man einen klartraum sagen
wenn du zum beispiel weiß dass du
träumst du wenn du eine bestimmte
aufgabe im traum machst dann gibst du
mir meinen augen signal weil ja wie herr
klein angesagt hat die augen die bewegen
sich sowieso das heißt diese muskeln
funktionieren auf alle fälle und man hat
auch festgestellt dass diese bewegungen
wenn man sich bewusst im traum aus führt
teilweise eben wirklich mit dem auge
ausgeführt werden das heißt ich kann
sagen mach einen links rechts links
rechts links rechts und man sieht dann
halt anhand des eeg und des muskeltonus
das ist eindeutig schlaf das ist
eindeutig rem-schlaf derjenige ist nicht
aber als schlaf- und mainz ist das
muster mit ideen spring natürlich ist es
auch kein eindeutiger beweis weil es
kann auch seine jährige nur träumt er
übt dieses augen signal
deswegen wecken wir dann trotzdem fragen
was hat er geträumt und dann als jetzt
an den traum bericht hoffentlich und
sagt ich habe auch dieses signal gemacht
so kann man dann halt dann haben wir
nichts zu verlieren
eine eine wunderbare schöne
forschungswelt weil wir sagen es geht
weil der proband der klar träume
freiwillig mitmacht weil wir müssen
zuerst einmal wissen wie sein wie es
funktioniert das gibt er uns preis
freiwillig und dann gehen wir in den
raum hinein und da kommt er wieder
zurück der proband aber was ist
eigentlich wenn jemand nicht freiwillig
und dafür hätte ich jetzt wiederum angst
wenn ich manipuliert werden wenn man
mich abzapfen kann gericht
wir haben noch nicht ja also der mensch
ja der mensch hat viele boshafte ideen
also die traum nsa das sehe ich alles
noch ganz ganz ganz lange nicht
sie müssen das vorher mit den leuten
trainieren also ich glaube da gibt es
wirklich schlimmer ein bistro und es
gibt schlimmere bedrohungsszenarien also
gut ist also ist es gab versuche da hat
man nicht mit menschen sondern mit
ratten versucht da können sie auch
zeigen dass die träume hat man versucht
diese träume zu manipulieren dass das
geht einfach nicht
ja die diebe kommen bestimmte reize
gelernt die werden dann die werden dann
in der nacht wieder abgespielt und sieht
man dass ihr dann gewisse gehirn
erregungen haben es gibt keinen grund
warum das bei menschen nicht
funktionieren sollte ich bin sicher dass
das funktioniert so ist das jetzt gut
oder schlecht dass das funktioniert
glaube es ist wie so häufig in der
wissenschaft
beides natürlich gibt es möglichkeiten
der manipulation aber es gibt natürlich
auch chancen sie sie können das zum
beispiel nutzen für für psychotherapien
bei bei leuten die wirklich sehr schwer
belastet sind durch traumatische
erfahrungen also für mich für mich
persönlich überwiegt bei weitem die
faszination der traum was und das ist
hier würden sich gern einen scanner zu
weihnachten wünschen in wien station auf
dem markt gäbe ja ich würde mich doch
einlegen würden in ihrer frauen nicht
unbedingt resultate zeigen doch doch
doch doch das an das würde ich auch
machen ich glaube ich glaube wir sind
viel zu eher positiv mit unseren träumen
gut aber ich merke auch ein bisschen
immer wieder auch im buch wenn man spürt
wenn man ihnen das reizwort sigmund
freud zu spielt oder dass da etwas
passiert weiß ich jetzt gern mal
versuchen würde also eben und freud
quasi also seit wir zeit unsere
gegenwart wenn man von traum spricht
dann sollte man irgendwo indirekt auch
über die die zwei um deutung von herrn
freut wir reden natürlich dann auch über
die frage wer sind wir über das ich und
diese instanzen modelle und so weiter
wer ist dann der träumende also ich bin
der neandertaler ich bin der vogel ich
bin der archaische ich bin der
wenn ich sowieso bin ich bin sie
arbeiten mit sportlern die sport
bewegungen einüben müssen also ich kann
das optimieren dass ich bin was ist
dieses ich eigentlich ja dieses ich sind
ganz viele verschiedene dass sie diese
zähne und instanzen und das ist das ist
die zwiebel die die miteinander zu tun
haben aber das ist das ist eben kein das
ist eben kein harter tennisball den man
anfassen kann und sagen da ist es
sondern das ist die zwiebel die hat die
hat verschiedene schichten die
miteinander in verbindung sind und da
lernen wir im traum wirklich etwas über
uns selbst wenn wir im traum zum
beispiel erleben wie die erinnerungen
entstehen wie erinnerungen angelegt
werden wie die abgerufen werden das sind
schichten des wegs auf die wir tagsüber
wirklich sehr schlecht zugriff haben und
trotzdem wollen wir jetzt einen
tötungsversuch machen mit ihnen weiter
wenn sie lust haben als zuschauer der
sendung konnten träume und zu schicken
und haben das auch gemacht und wir haben
zwei ausgewählt einen ersten von zwei
bis elmar ausbleiben
ich fahre auf skis einen hang hinunter
nicht weiter ungewöhnlich ich fahre ohne
kurve geradeaus es wird immer steiler
immer schneller
irgendwann weiß ich dass ich kaum mehr
bremsen kann und dann kommt der punkt
soll ich über einen abhang oder eine
chance fahre und abhebe in der luft der
wache ich dann und das ist schreibt dann
der träumer noch weiter ein ein
ängstliches gefühl also eine bedrohung
aber beim aufwachen ist es dann etwas
schönes also jetzt sind sie nicht
erfreut und sie sind nicht 1900 und das
ist ein 2014
was lesen sie an seine frau geschrieben
naja es ist ein ziemlich typischer traum
nicht der ist der ist insofern tückisch
als das der träumer sehr in bewegung ist
im traum sind wir meistens in bewegung
das hat wahrscheinlich etwas damit zu
tun dass wir vor allem in der
rentenphase in denen wir besonders
intensiv träumen bewegungen trainieren
also das ist ja genau das worüber frau
schädlich arbeitet und darum
funktioniert das auch was was frau
schädlich macht bei der bei der bei
diesen bewegungs lernen im traum und
träumen hat wirklich sehr viel mit mit
lernen zu tun also nicht mit
vergangenheit sondern mit zukunft naja
ich lerne etwas für die zukunft bei
diesen bei diesem ganz elementaren
bewegungs lernen das spielt natürlich so
etwas wegen gleichgewicht sind eine ganz
wichtige rolle und wenn der trainiert
wird oder ein bisschen aus der just a
gigolo können sie das gefühl haben sie
fliegen das kann sehr schön sein weil ja
hier vielleicht jetzt gar nicht die
bewegung so sehr im vordergrund stand
sondern vielleicht wieder die angst
emotionen wobei ich auch das anliegen
fand die emotionen gar nicht so sehr
beschrieben wurden aber das kann
vielleicht dann später noch aber ich
fand auch interessant dass wir im traum
eine ängstliche emotionen da war und
beim aufwachen dann doch eine gute aber
vielleicht war das auch die
erleichterung
ich bin wach und ich bin jetzt doch
nicht weggeflogen aber es kann ja jetzt
auch wirklich sein dass da dieses
angstgefühl man steuert unkontrolliert
auf etwas zu was man nicht abwenden kann
einfach den traum hervorgerufen hat und
dann mit chinas ist ich also dieses ihr
traum klar traurig ist eine
kontrollierende analysierende instanz
die sie einbauen können ihr antrag
insofern die gefühle auch wahrnehmen und
versuchen zu steuern
und dann auf eine zukunftsperspektive
hin ausgerichtet also dass das sie in
einem sinn ihr leben bestimmt
etwas aus dem trauma rauskommt und da
wären wir durch wieder irgendwo in der
antike oder in der in der frühen
geschichte als ein traum ist ein omen
es ist etwas was sind die zukunft weiß
also schon eine mögliche welt das glaube
ich schon aber eben keine prophezeiung
aber das ist doch also es sind ja auch
an der grenze zwischen ich weiß nicht
wer das ist das nicht eine
sozialwissenschaftliche oder das finde
ich das finde ich schon wissenschaftlich
denn was unser gehirn totes
experimentiert mit hypothesen über die
welt über mich selbst über unser leben
und und das und das passiert und das
passiert im trauma und werden
möglichkeiten durchgespielt wie wäre es
wenn ich kinder hätte oder keine kinder
hätte aber aber das ist sehen sie es
gibt es gibt einen unterschied zwischen
einer hypothese die ich ja dann
verifizieren dann sagen das ist so und
einer und einer prophezeihung die sagt
das muss so sein
du hast keine freiheiten ich glaube der
traum gibt uns diese freiheit ja ich
denke genau auch dass der traum impulse
geben kann also man verarbeitet jetzt
irgendein thema was ein zum beispiel
emotional sehr aufgewühlt hat wie das
beispiel auch in ihrem buch mit der
tochter oder ich hatte auch mal ein
ähnliches kommunikationsproblem mit
einer person die mir nahe stand und habe
dann aber auch wieder dieses typische
diesen typischen abitur traum gehabt
dass das abitur mehr aberkannt wurde
weil ich angeblich geschummelt hätte und
ich musste mich gegen alle welt
verteidigen ich habe doch gar nicht
geschummelt
aber als ich den trend also durch
gelesen habe wusste ich genau das
bezieht sich eigentlich auf dieses
kommunikationsproblemen das hat mit
anstoß gegeben das zu klären mit der
person also da einfach nochmals das
gespräch zu suchen weil ich dann die
idee hatte ja wir haben einfach
verschiedene perspektiven ähnlich wie
auch in ihrem traum das heißt ein traum
kann schon für die zukunft einen impuls
geben einfach weil man sich damit
beschäftigt weil man sich daran erinnert
aber genau was jetzt prophezeiung an
geht es natürlich ganz anderes feld und
es gibt auch diesen begriff des dvs ist
dass ihnen ein begriff haben wir haben
sie selber erfahrungen mit na ja dass
das dafür hat man das gefühl hat man ja
eher tagsüber nicht ja dass man im plan
soll also einfach schnell über das ist
das typische dichter wie es tagsüber man
denkt ach das habe ich schon mal erlebt
aber im traum hat man oft erinnerungen
wo man nicht genau weiß das genau
tja oder genau man denkt ach das habe
ich ja schon mal geträumt oder acht habe
ich erst mal erlebt aber wenn man
aufwacht denkt hey quatsch das habe ich
ja gar nicht einmal geträumt habe man
nicht verifizieren weil kann ja sein
dass man in diesen traumzustand sich
wirklich an den früheren traumzustand
erinnern kann auf den wir im wachzustand
keinen zugriff haben also damit
erinnerungen traum da vermischt sich
ganz viel ich glaube ich dass ich glaube
dass dieser deal hat ganz viel damit zu
tun dass unsere gehirn eben eine
hypothese nein hypothesen generieren das
organ ist nicht und ich komme in eine
ich komme in eine neue situation ich
schaue gar nicht so genau hin
und das erinnert mich ganz stark an
etwas aber ich weiß nicht so genau woran
ist mich erinnert nicht und dann und
dann habe ich dieses déjà vu gefühl und
das kann das glaube ich schon
das kann auch an träume erinnern weil
eben im traum dieser erinnerungen
reorganisiert und angelegt werden also
das schlüssel trotz allem also ist
vielleicht weniger die sprache die
sprache gelungen eine komische
übersetzungs die wieder in symbolen auch
gefangen dann abonnieren sie jetzt schon
genau also die emotionen ersetzen die
sprache dann gewissen sind viele
elementare weil sie ihnen die
vergangenheit und die zukunft weil sie
die tiere sehen
erstmal sind wir tiere und dann ist da
noch so ein bisschen tritt naja dann ist
eine menge präfrontaler kortex erdenken
sprachen kerns investiere und emotional
da steht ja immer zu uns sind einfach
wichtig genau deswegen treten sie einen
träumen wieder auf und anhand dieser
emotionen verknüpft man dann eine menge
also das heißt auch noch einmal
versuchen ein bisschen zusammen zu
fassen also weiter zu gehen wenn wir
jetzt diese träume und die sind diesen
drittel des lebens fruchtbar machen
möchten und und uns nicht abkoppeln von
diesem drittel des lebens wäre ja schade
er einfach von oder zeitverschwendung
die relevanz für das leben des träumens
also wir brauchen schlaf aus
biologischen gründen
wir brauchen ihn als psychologischen
gründen wir haben gemerkt wir können ihn
aber noch ausnutzen traum als
trainingsraum sie arbeiten mit sportlern
damit die welt zu werden im traum
genauso wir forschen zumindest erstmal
inwiefern man das klarträumen eben dafür
nutzen kann
wobei ich den fokus gar nicht so sehr
darauf legen würde
man muss den traum unbedingt jetzt noch
hinzuziehen um einfach mehr
trainingszeit zu haben es ist eher ein
anderer qualitativer zustand wo man auch
eben weil man kreativer ist auch im
traum vielleicht noch einen neuen
blickwinkel kriegt also ich habe auch
sportler interviewte ihre klarträumen
tatsächlich nutzen um bewegungsabläufe
zu trainieren und die finden das einfach
wahnsinn weil man da noch mal ein ganz
anderes körpergefühl hat und weil man
tolle möglichkeiten hat die man dass man
ist eben schwerelos man kann ja simon
hamann unser skispringen kann probieren
kann auch in zeitlupe springen
also man hat halt viel mehr
möglichkeiten man kann natürlich auch im
wachzustand teil trainieren also dass
man die augen schließt und sich
vorstellt ich mache jetzt diese bewegung
das ist aber nicht sehr realistisch wenn
man es im traum macht fühlt es sich
wirklich so an vom körper als würde man
es wirklich machen und auch die leute
die ich interviewt habe die nutzen das
eben machen was langsamer oder schneller
oder spiegelverkehrt was aber macht euch
dann nicht so gut klappt oder schwimmen
zum beispiel der einheitsliste
verbessert schwimmen durch ein anderes
element
die eine hat kampfsport gemacht und hat
sich dann im traum einen kampf partner
herget aber der dieselbe größe und
statur hat wie sie weil das für sie
wichtig war zum trainieren
solche dinge kann man dann halt einfach
spielerisch auch austesten ich will
jetzt gar nicht so sagen jeder muss im
traum seine leistung noch steigern aber
einfach mal das auszuprobieren dass die
nicht verlieren gibt es grenzen
auf alle fälle zum beispiel was ich
jetzt in der studie mit interviews und
biss
herauskristallisiert ist zum beispiel
das team sport wäre gesagt ja es war
dann hast dann hat man die anderen leute
und wie der traum so ist die machen dann
über irgendwas die traum charaktere und
dann fangen die auf dem fußballfeld
plötzlich einen irgendwie bier zu
trinken oder irgendwas was man
vielleicht wieder mit den leuten also
zitiert gerade was die sonst so im
alltag machen deswegen entstehen der
dynamiken aber trotzdem auch da kann man
kreativ den klartraum nutzen zum
beispiel hat ein proband mir erzählt
erträumt dann vom trainer via noch mal
strategisch spielzüge an der tafel
aufzeichnet und geht die noch mal durch
und es verfestigt habe ich schon wieder
ein zurück geben
also ich habe sie nicht an davon
ausgegangen dass das was ich träume ich
bin mit diesem ich zu tun und sagen sie
aber auch der bier trinken die zuschauer
sowie 50.000 stadion dass niemand anders
da im traum das ist anders sie können
doch tatsächlich einen einfluss auf
diesem tag an dem ich dann wirklich
nicht steuern kommen es ist ja im
normalen traum auch sowie begegnen
leuten die machen wir irgendwas aber der
wahl ohne gesicht bei hitchcocks ja das
bin auch ich weil oder die mut eure
erfahrung ist auch bin auch ich weiß
dass ist vor
das ist etwas was ich war nimmt dem
moment aber es ist natürlich auch das
ist natürlich auch eine frau bringt ihre
ski jetzt also im grunde genommen ein
traum ist eine das ist eine virtuelle
welt und zwar eine erstaunlich gut die
virtuelle welt die sie sich diese sich
selbst erschaffen ich glaube das ist die
ich glaube das ist die pointe also sie
sind im traum zugleich so etwas wie
akteur also also ein held aber sie sind
auch szenenbildner und sie sind
regisseur das sind sie halt in
unterschiedlich bewusst maß also im
klassen sie häufig in gewissem maße dass
sie dass sie regie führen können in
anderen träumen wissen es nicht aber es
ist trotzdem alles ihnen entsprungen
woher soll denn sonst kommen
na klar aber wenn es daneben sich eben
grenzen ja eben weil man so sehr
assoziiert im traum deswegen wieder
nicht jede rolle ganz genau wer viel zu
anstrengend wenn man die alle definieren
ist also ich finde es auch gerade das
faszinierende dass selbst wenn man weiß
dass man träumt immer noch irgendwas
etwas an überrascht natürlich kommt das
aus einem selber heraus aber man ist
auch viel kreativer als man sich glaube
ich glaube solche träume können uns
lernen ein stückweit demütig zu werden
und unserer ich nicht ganz so verdammt
wichtig zu nehmen nicht also ganz viele
hypothesen traum charaktere zum beispiel
dann wirklichkeit wahrnehmungen die
erzeugt unser geist ohne dass dieses ich
das dauernd kontrollieren wir sagen das
bin ich das das da dass das eine rolle
spielt lasst euch nicht so auf leute da
jemand der mit diesem ich sehr intensiv
auseinandergesetzt hat und nach diesen
kreativen fundus des theaters gebracht
hat und direkt umgesetzt hat ist franz
kafka den sie auch zitieren und und in
ihrem buch und schreibt ja
offensichtlich dann im traum zeigen sich
schreckliche wahrheiten aufdringlich und
überdeutlich so wie sie dem matten tages
leben niemals zum durchbruch kommen
können
und das hat jetzt ein bisschen wie soll
ich sagen nach psychoanalytische selbst
psychoanalytische funktion hier eine
zeichnung übrigens von kraft eine
zeichnung wir ihn sehen quasi mit mit
mit monster geflügelten fabelwesen um
ihn herum wie nachtwache von 5 auf ihn
einwirken
also das heißt dieses ich kann man auch
psychotherapeutisch reinigen oder also
weiterbringen im traum
das ist etwas was in
das geschieht sehr häufig von selbst
also im traum im traum werden
erinnerungen verarbeitet gerade im
rem-schlaf spielen gefühle eine wichtige
rolle und eines was da sehr häufig
passiert ist das ist dass gefühle
verarbeitet werden indem sie bestimmte
belastende situationen wieder erleben so
was wie eine tragen sie ja der ja im
albtraum ist es eben schief gegangen
also im albtraum kommt diese
verarbeitung nicht zu ihrem ende weil
das gefühl so stark ist dass sie
aufwachen und dann passiert genau so
häufig genau das gegenteil von dem was
also was evolutionär erwünscht ist dann
brennt sich nämlich die erinnerung noch
tiefer ein
oder dann wenn sich die gefühlte
erinnerung noch tief ein drittel das
will man eigentlich nicht haben also das
weiß man aus traum serien die
ausgewertet worden sind von leuten
dramatisieren
traumatisierte ja also kriegsopfer opfer
von irgendwelchen verbrechen und
unfällen usw
und da sieht man dass sich die träume
mit der zeit verändern und die sind
anfangs sehr wirklichkeitsnah und sehr
emotional und die werden mit der zeit
immer bizarrer und weniger dass ich ein
alter schlager ist das ein gutes zeichen
ja absurd aber wird das da wird es ja
genau das wird die dann wird die
emotionen verarbeitet man kann natürlich
auch die klar träume sehr gut nutzen um
albträume die nicht anders weg gehen
oder nicht von selbst weg gehen
aufzulösen also wenn man natürlich im
albtraum erkennt dass es ein traum ist
ist das natürlich super weil man dann
versuchen kann diese emotionen klein zu
halten oder den traum zu verändern sich
der gefahr zu stellen
zur not zu wecken wobei ich das nicht
für die ideale lösung halte aber das ist
sehr gutes kennt das verfahren ja ja
also ich habe hin und wieder albträume
ich werde leider darin nicht so oft klar
weil das problem ist dass man da oft
sehr von den emotionen eingenommen ist
und dann nicht diesen bewussten fokus
hat aber wenn man es mal schafft ist es
ja sehr gut
es kann natürlich auch trotzdem auch da
kann die emotionen sind
hagen sein dass es trotz des laderaums
noch ein bisschen bestehen bleibt aber
es ist an sich ein sehr gutes mittel um
dagegen anzukämpfen gibt's dann gibt es
ein quasi auch den tumor oder man sagt
ja manchmal im leben also wenn man etwas
mit humor nimmt geht es leichter ist
darum eine eine lustige flat träume ich
finde träume häufig eine wahnsinnig
komische welt und ich freue mich an
meinen träumen
also was da alles für verrückte und
absurde einfälle drin stecken hätte ich
mir im wach- leben überhaupt nicht
zugetraut aber der also ich bin kein
sehr häufiger klar träume daher in
normalen traum merke ich das nicht mehr
weil das komische zu sehen also da
braucht man eine gewisse distanz
manchmal sagt man braucht auch verstand
also das komische ist die entdeckung im
traum er in erinnerung
sie brauchen ein bisschen abstand um
über sich und ihre innere welt lachen zu
können glaube das hängt auch sehr von
der person ab und der herren jeweils
gemütszustand also ich hatte sowohl
nicht klare träume als auch klar träume
in denen ich so gelacht habe das anlegen
mit dem lachen am hals aufgewacht bin ja
jetzt also aber das finden sie danach
noch lustig wenn sie sich daran
also dann vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so
oft ist es so dass sowieso im traum die
gefühle ja übersteigert sind man
empfindet vielmehr trauer vieler wut als
man in derselben situation denn sie
überhaupt so möglich ist im wachzustand
tun würde und so ist es mit der komik
auch also ich hab zum beispiel manchmal
ein traum charakter dichten lassen und
habe einmal meine schwester gebeten im
gedicht aufzusagen
sie sagte ich bin ein wanst und ich
konnte mithalten danach mit aufgewacht
oder man kann auch ein klartraum so
später machen wie eben weil der traum
von selbst so kreativ ist lass mich
überraschen mich zeigt etwas lustiges
dann geht man eine ecke und da ist
irgendwas lustig ich habe das total
komische bilder gesehen von denen ich
auch lachende aufgewacht bin und dann
geht man von mit einem ganz anderen
gefühl in den tag
die die kreativität werde mich noch was
setzen auch dass das aufzunehmen dass
wir die emotionen das nicht messbare
kreativität gehört für mich dazu man
kann nicht sagen ist jetzt ein
ein gutes gedicht im team geschrieben
besser oder schlechter die manipulation
beim sport kann man es messen ob jemand
schneller besser ist nach dem schlafen
dass wir eine wissenschaft haben die uns
auf die schliche kommt immer mehr und
immer näher und daneben dann auch diese
emotionen noch messen kann vielleicht
sogar manipulieren kann ist es ist
grauenhaft sich vorzustellen dass diese
kreativität design eine art von
geheimnis ist dort eine gabe etwas wo
man nicht weiß wann sie kommt man sie
geht wenn der chemie einem einem etwas
in die lewa ca
ja natürlich aber das dass das alles mit
dem traum zu tun hat und man diesen
traum diese traumwelt auch wie
beschützen möchte als letztes reservat
der nicht aus gold barren existenz weil
du nicht konsumieren weil ich nicht
trainieren weil wir lernen weil wir
nicht performativ sein wollen sondern
weil wir uns diesem diesem wahnsinns
trinker einfach auch hingeben möchten
aber ist etwas also dass das das geht
mir genauso also ich persönlich will
meine träume überhaupt nicht nutzen aber
kunststücke ich bin ja auch kein
leistungssportler
also für mich sind träume ebene sind
eine ganz starke ästhetische erfahrung
also ich erlebe träume so wie wenn ich
ins museum gehen oder wie wenig eine
wenn ich eine reise mache oder ins
konzert gehen
es ist eine ganz große bereicherung
meines lebens aber ist etwas ist etwas
schlimmes dabei wenn ich dabei nebenbei
auch noch erfahre wie meine erinnerungen
angelegt werden wie ich wie ich auf neue
gedanken kommen also für mich steigert
steigern diese erkenntnisse das
faszinosum ist könnte auch als wenn
dieser super scan oder er einst kommt
dass man sagt ich muss gar nicht mehr
reisen ich muss gar nicht mehr mich
verlieben ich muss ein das leben weil
ich kann das ja irgendwie
elektronisch gesteuert wie bei diesen
versuchen einfach diese impulse schicken
und dann geht die post ab und und der
traum als als reservoir übernimmt das
wach leben selbst sehen sie hier
man träumt ja ähnlich die ganze zeit
also ich finde man kann genauso sein
wach leben aus leben in all seinen
facetten wie seine traumwelt genau also
natürlich könnte man sagen man könnte
sich jetzt nur noch in diese traumwelt
flüchtet tagsüber macht nichts man
richtig ist aber ich denke dass bereich
hat sich auch gegenseitig und ich glaube
das ist ich glaube die frage ist doch
viel eher wie wollen wir leben und diese
freiheit wird und und wie bewusst wollen
wir leben und diese frage stellt sich
uns tags da bis da ist uns das noch
einigermaßen klar auch wenn wir häufig
nicht danach handeln das einigermaßen
klar dass ich diese frage stellt und im
traum entdecken werden so was wir noch
mal ein drittel unseres lebens noch mal
eine ja dass gerade nochmal noch mal
eine ganze welt und wir haben und wir
haben die chance das bewusst
wahrzunehmen und wir können genauso
entscheidungen treffen wie wir damit
umgehen wollen
ich sehe das genauso auch gar nicht als
gefahr sondern als quelle und wissen
eigentlich alle kreativ also auch die
die sich tagsüber nicht für kreativ
halten wenn man sich seine träume
anschaut sieht man essen und die die eh
schon schöpferisch tätig sind die können
aus ihren träumen noch mal so viel
inspiration herausziehen also es ist
damit zwar nicht jetzt gut leben das ist
dass ich diesen zugang habe dass ich
mich nicht abkoppeln dass ich nicht
meine dass ich das quasi als symbolik
nicht selbstständig und china
erschließen kann sondern dass ich diese
sphären zwischen bach und schlaf dass
ich die dynamisch und und interaktiv
wahrnehmen kann damit spielen kann sehr
lange spielen kann bin ich bei ihnen
fällig bei ihnen jetzt würde mich zum
schluss natürlich noch interessieren
gibt es einen traum den sie noch träumen
möchten indem sie noch auf der
einkaufsliste hafen der 1
es gibt noch ganz viele träume ist noch
träumen möchte also ich wollte immer
schon mal versuchen mich in den delfinen
zu verwandeln und bisschen etwas habe
ich noch nicht so gut geschafft im klang
weil diese verwandlung geschichten sind
zumindest für mich ziemlich schwierig es
gibt noch ganz viele andere ideen ist es
bei ihnen keine träume auf der
einkaufsliste sondern also träume ist
etwas was zu mir kommt und da lasse ich
mich überraschen und das ist das ist für
mich genau der reiz dass ich da dass ich
dann nichts will und dass ich da einfach
staunen kann über diese welt vielen dank
aber es ist noch nicht ausgeträumt denn
nachts wach widmet dem traum am
kommenden dienstag hat mitternacht eine
sendung und in der sternstunde
philosophie sehen sie nächste woche eine
sondersendung zu china als dem gottlieb
duttweiler institute in rüschlikon unter
anderem mit bundesrat hier haben es
schneider-ammann kinder
[Musik]